we've already spent some time looking at
the ideal gas law and also thinking
about scenarios where things might
diverge from what at least the ideal gas
law might predict and what we're going
to do in this video is dig a little bit
deeper into scenarios where we might
diverge a little bit from the ideal gas
law or maybe i guess a lot a bit
in certain situations
so i have three scenarios here this
first scenario right over here i have a
high temperature
high temperature
and i have a large
volume
and both of these are really important
because when we think about when we get
close to being ideal that's situations
where the volume of the particles
themselves are negligible to the volume
of the container and at least here it
looks like that might be the case
because we're dealing with a very large
volume even this isn't drawn to scale i
just drew the particles this size so
that you could see them and high
temperature that helps us realize that
well maybe the inter par intermolecular
interactions or attractions between the
particles aren't going to be that
significant and so in a high temperature
large volume scenario this might be
pretty close to ideal
now it's not going to be perfectly ideal
because real gases have some volume and
they do have some intermolecular
interactions but now let's change things
up a little bit let's now move to the
same volume so we're still dealing with
a large volume
but let's lower the temperature
it's a low
temperature and we can see because
temperature is proportional to average
kinetic energy of the particles that
here these arrows on average are a
little bit smaller and let's say we
lower the temperature close to the
condensation point remember the
condensation point of a gas that's a
situation where the molecules are
attracting each other and even starting
to clump up together they're starting to
if we're thinking about say water vapors
they're starting to get into little
droplets of of liquid water because
they're getting so attracted to each
other
so in this situation where we have just
lowered the temperature
the ideal gas law would already predict
that if you keep everything else
constant that the pressure would go down
if we solve for pressure we would have p
is equal to n rt over v so if you just
lower temperature the ideal gas law
would already predict that your pressure
would be lower
but in this situation with a real gas
because we're close to that condensation
point these gases these particles are
more and more attracted to each other so
they're less likely to bump into the
sides of the container or if they do
they're going to do it with less vigor
so in this situation for a real gas
because of the intermolecular traction
between the particles you would actually
have a lower pressure than even the
ideal gas law would predict ideal gas
law would already predict that if you
lower the temperature pressure would go
down but you would see that a real gas
in this scenario p
even lower
even lower for a real gas
now let's go to another scenario let's
go to a scenario where we keep
the high temperature
that we had in the original scenario but
now we have a small volume
small
volume maybe this top of the container
is a piston and we push it down like
this
well the ideal gas law if we just solve
for p again p is equal to n rt over v it
would already predict that if you
decrease the denominator here that's
going to increase the value of the
entire expression so it would already
predict that you would have a higher
pressure that the particles will bounce
into the sides of the container more
frequently and with more vigor but if we
have a really small volume of the
container we no longer can assume that
the volume of the particles themselves
are going to be negligible compared to
the volume of the container and so the
effective volume to move around in is
even lower than we're seeing in this
equation so these particles have even
less space to bounce around it because
they take up some of the space so
they're going to bounce off the sides of
the container more frequently and even
more vigor so here pressure even
even higher for a real gas than what is
predicted by the ideal gas law